اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
اسرائيل تطالب الفصائل الفلسطينيه بازاله
الصواريخ ومنصاتها كليا ووزير دفاعها يامر
بالاستعداد لعمليات اضافيه
تعلن بدء الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد في
باخموت والكرملين يهدد بالرد على الصواريخ
بعيده المدى لك
المحكمه العليا في باكستان تامر باطلاق
سراح عمران خان وتعتبر اعتقاله غير قانوني
وعدد النازحين حول العالم يصل الى مستويات
قياسيه بسبب الحروب وتغير المناخ
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
يتواصل التصعيد في غزه في ظل عدم بروز افق
لتهدئه حتى الان جليل التطورات هو دعوه
اسرائيل للفصائل الفلسطينيه بازاله
الصواريخ ومنصاتها كليا هذا في وقت اعلنت
فيه تل ابيب ان الجيش جدد قصفه على مواقع
للجهاد في غزه في حين اكد وزير الدفاع
ضروره اليقظه لتوسيع دائره اطلاق النار
داعيا الى الاستعداد لسلسله عمليات اضافيه
في القطع
[موسيقى]
وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري اكد ان
جهود التهدئه بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
مستمره لكنها لم تؤتي نتائجها المرجوه حتى
الان وطلب شكري المجتمع الدولي بالتدخل
لوقف ما يتعرض له الشعب الفلسطيني اننا
نطالب المجتمع الدولي الذي يقع على عاتقه
ايضا مسؤوليه السياسيه وقانونيه وانسانيه
فيما الت اليه الاوضاع الشعب الفلسطيني
بان يبدي ذات الحماسه والتصميم لمعالجه
تلك القضيه العادله كما ابداها بالنسبه
للازمات القائمه الاخرى واؤكد ان الجهود
المصريه المستمره في هذا الصدر بما في ذلك
في سياق الاحداث الاخيره بخطاع غزه سواء
اعترف الى النزاع او المجتمع الدولي من
اجل التهدئه وسعيا لاستئناف العمليه
السياسيه
هذا ورغم ما نبذله من جهود مدنيه الا ان
تلك الجهود ما زالت لم تؤتي ثمارها
ونتائجها المرجوه
الى ذلك حث وزراء خارجيه كل من مصر الاردن
فرنسا والمانيا بحثوا على ضروره انهاء
الاعمال العنف بين اسرائيل والقطاع
وصرحت وزيره خارجيه المانيا انالينا
بيربوك انه يجب وقف الدماء على الفور
وادانا وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري
الاعمال العدائيه في حين اشار نظيره
الاردني ايمن الصفدي الى انه يجب استعاده
السلام بين الطرفين
من حدود قطاع غزه الزميل زياد حلبي مدير
مكتب العربيه في فلسطين يتابع التطورات
الميدانيه لحظه بلحظه زياد اهلا وسهلا بك
مجددا جديد المشهد الميداني زياد وهل
الامور ذاهبه باتجاه التهدئه في الساعات
المقبله ام لا الامور غير واضحه تماما
ليس واضحا هذا الامر
الواضح بان ثمه تصعيدا قد ياتي في وقت
القصير
الوشيك طبعا بعد ان اغتالت اسرائيل قبل
قليل قياديا اخر في سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري للجهاد الاسلامي احمد ابو دقه 40
عاما وهو نائب قائد وحده الصواريخ الوحده
الصاروخيه في سرايا القدس التابعه للجهاد
علي غالي الذي اغتالته عند منتصف الليله
الماضيه في شقه في خان يونس جنوبي قطاع
غزه هذا الاغتيال الجديد الان بالاضافه
الى استمرار الاغتيالات قد يقود الفصائل
وخاصه الجهاد الاسلامي الى رد كبير نسبيا
ومكثف قد يطال وسط اسرائيل وتل ابيب هذا
ما تخشى اسرائيل بهذا رايناها في الساعات
الاخيره تشن غارات استباقيه جوا وبحرا وب
على عشرات المواقع في قطاع غزه التي تفترض
بان فيها منصات اطلاق صواريخ خشيه من هذه
الضربه قبل قليل كان هناك عمليه اعتراض في
هذه المنطقه الان اسمع اصوات مقاتلات اف
16 ربما ستكون بعد قليل غارات في شمال
قطاع غزه من خلفنا زياد قبل ان اسالك عن
حظوظ الوساطه المصريه في الساعات المقبله
يظل السؤال لماذا اثرت حركه حماس عدم
الدخول في هذه المواجهه برغم كل البيانات
والغرف المشتركه
بينها وبين الفصائل الاخرى تحديدا الجهاد
حماس تقول انها تشارك
والبيانات الصادره عن الغرفه العمليات
المشتركه تقول بان الرد هو من كافه
الفصائل وليس فقط الجاد الاسلامي لكن ما
من شك بان الجهاد الاسلامي التقود عمليه
الرد بقوه ناريه هائله نسبيا عمليا وهي
التي تقوم باستهداف تل ابيب بصواريخ
تملكها لديها قدره صاروخيه عمليا
ادعاء حتى اسرائيل لديها قوه ناريه لا
يستهان بها رغم انها فصيل تعتبر صغيرا اذا
ما قرنا بحماس وبقدرات حماس ولكن عمليا هي
من يقود هذا العمل العسكري ضد على اسرائيل
حاليا اخيرا زياد هل يمكن القول ان
الوسطاء المصريين يملكون فرصه في احقاق
تهدئه في الساعات المقبله ووفق اي شروط
يعني في شروط من هنا وشروط من هناك يعني
انه الفصائل ببدا ضمانات بان اسرائيل لن
تتعرض لقادتها في حين اسرائيل تريد وق ف
تصنيع الصواريخ في غزه وسوى ذلك من كلام
هذا هذه شروط متبادله وضعت على مائده
الوسيط المصري الذي عمليا استقبل وفدا من
الجهاد الاسلامي في القاهره ويرسل وفدا
الى تل ابيب للقاء الاسرائيليين هذه
المواقف هي تبدو مواقف افتتاحيه ولكن لن
يطول تطول هذه المفاوضات كثيرا بمعنى هناك
شروط من الجانبين وضعت في نهايه المطاف
يتم ايجاد صيغه ما تعلن فيها يعلم فيها
وقف اطلاق نار متبادل ومتزامن تحت وساطه
مصريه نعرف ذلك يقينا خلال ساعات او يوم
او يومين لا فرقه في هذا الموضوع ولكن في
النهايه هذا هو السيناريو المتوقع عمليا
ودعنا نقول شبه الاكيد ولكن في انتظار ذلك
سترى تصعيد نوعيا من الجانبين وهذا كله
منذ الامس المشهد الختامي كي الوعي للمشهد
الختامي من الجانبين هذا نراه بوضوح
اسرائيل تواصل
الى شان اخر الان فقد اعلن قائد مجموعه
فاجنر يفغيني ان الوحدات الاوكرانيه بدات
هجومها المضاد مقتربه من محيط مدينه بخموت
كما صرح عبر التليجرام ان بعض عمليات
الوحدات كانت ناجحه جزئيا وعلق على
تصريحات الرئيس الاوكراني حول تاخير
الهجوم المضاد قائلا نازلنسكي كان مخادعا
بتصريحاته حسب وصف بريكوجين
الرئيس الاوكراني
كان قد قال ان بلاده بحاجه الى مزيد من
الوقت لشن هجوم مضاد ضد القوات الروسيه
فالوقت الذي ينتظر الجيش تسلم المساعدات
العسكريه الموعوده واضاف زيلينسكي ان
القوات التي تم تدريبها من قبل الديتو
اصبحت جاهزه للقتال لكن الجيش لا يزال
بحاجه الى معدات اكثر بما في ذلك العربات
المدرعه
الرئيس الاوكراني اشار الى امكانيه المضي
بشن الهجوم لكن هناك مخاوف ما يحتم
الانتظار لبعض الوقت مشددا في الوقت عينها
على عدم التخلي عن اي جزء من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه لروسيا
ينضم الى يمين دونات العربيه رائد الاكبر
لمزيد من المتابعه اهلا وسهلا بك اخر
اخبار الشريط الميدانيه رائد خصوصا وان
بريجوجين يقول ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
على بخ مت قد بدا الى هذا الكلام ما يؤكده
على ارض الواقع
مرحبا طالب بالفعل الهجوم بدا ومنذ ايام
حيث ان المقاطعه هنا
تشهد باستمرار قصفا وتيره ارتفعت نسبيا
حيث ان القصف الاوكراني باتا يطال المدينه
واطراف المدينه صباح اليوم هناك ثلاثه
اصابات ليس هناك اي من قتلى اليوم يصادف
طبعا
الذكرة التاسعه
للاستئناف عفوا للاستفتاء الاول
والاستقلال عن اوكرانيا بالنسبه
للانفصاليين هنا وهناك تحذير من السلطات
من الخروج الى الشوارع والتجول خشيه من
القصف الاوكراني لكن على
الشريط يعني الساخن جدا حيث المعارك
والحروب بالفعل هناك هجمات مضاده ليس في
باخمه وحدها انما في مارينكا في
اوغلادار هناك عمليات مرتده للقوات
الاوكرانيه حاولت الوصول الى نقاط تمركز
القوات الروسيه في افديفكا كذلك حاولت
العوده الى احد المواقع في مدينه مارينكا
هناك هجمات بالفعل مضاده تقول القوات
الروسيه بانها تصد هذه الهجمات وتنجح
بايقاف القوات الاوكرانيه من العوده ليس
هناك اي تقدم كان في محور
اوغلار او حتى مارنن كهناك عمليه دفاع وصد
للهجوم الاوكراني لكن محور باختم باخمت
وحده لو سمح لي الوقت وبعجاله طالب محور
باخمه هو الاهم حيث يوم امس قالت القوات
الاوكرانيه بانها سيطرت على كيلومترين من
الاراضي في مدينه باخمت كان هناك صمت من
الجانب الروسي لا الدفاع الروسي يتكلمت
ولا حتى
وقت متاخر ظهرت تصريحات
لقوات تقول بانه
فعل سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه على مواقع في
اجنحه المدينه في اطراف المدينه لكن ما
زالت قوات فاجنر تتقدم في العمق الغربي
وسيطرت على مزيد من الاراضي واظهرت
فيديوهات
لمقاتلي فاجنر يعني يتنقلون بين الابنيه
الشاهقه المعروف مكانها في اخر المدينه
وتحدثوا عن 700 متر يعني في العمق
الاوكراني المتبقي فقط لاكمال السيطره على
باقي ما تعذرني
من دونتسك مراسل العربيه رائد الاخضر
دائما شكرا جزيلا لك رائد على كل هذه
المتابعه
من جهه اخرى اعلن اب ولص وزير الدفاع
البريطاني ان بلاده قررت امداد كيف
بصواريخ ستورم شادو بعيده المدى
يستطيع ان اؤكد ان المملكه المتحده قررت
التبرع بصواريخ ستوب بعيده المدى الى
اوكرانيا هي صواريخ تقليديه قادره على
الضربات الدقيقه وتكمل مجموعه الصواريخ
بعيده المدى التي تم ارسالها لاوكرانيا
كهيمارس وهاربون ارسال هذه الصواريخ يمنح
اوكرانيا الفرصه للدفاع عن نفسها ضد
الوحشيه الروسيه خصوصا استهداف البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه المتعمد وهو ما ينتهك
القانون الدولي اوكرانيا يجب ان يكون لها
الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها ضد ذلك استخدام
القوات الروسيه بعيدا عن الاراضي
الاوكرانيه
ندد من جهته بخطط بريطانيا لتزويد
اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى وقال
المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ان هذه الخطوه التي وصفها بالسلبيه ستتطلب
ردا مناسبا من قبل الجيش الروسي
المتحدث باسم الكريم كان قد اقر بان
العمليه الروسيه في اوكرانيا صعبه للغايه
لكنه اكد ان روسيا نجحت في الحاق اضرار
كبيره بالجيش الاوكراني
حرب اوكرانيا العمليه العسكريه الروسيه
صعبه جدا لكنها ستستمر بدانا الحرب في
فبراير من عام 2022 وسيطرنا على اراض
اوكرانيه روسيا تمكنت من الحاق اضرار
جسيمه بقدرات اوكرانيا العسكريه نعمل على
وقف قصف ثياب للمناطق الشرقيه
نفذنا ضربات صاروخيه لا حصر لها وسنستمر
في هذا الخطاب قبل عام ونيف كان بوتين
عازما على تدمير من وصفهم بالنازيين الجدد
في اوكرانيا واليوم يقول الكرملين ان
العمليه صعبه ومعقده للغايه
فوفقا للمتحدث باسم الكريم
فان العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لم تحقق كل اهدافها هذه المهمه تحققت
جزئيا لكن لازلنا بعيدين عن تنفيذها بصوره
كامله ترون القصف بواسطه راجمات الصواريخ
قصف دونيتسك والمدن الاخرى مستمره لذلك
هناك حاجه الى ابعاد العدو الى مسافه
كبيره ولذلك ان العمليه ستستمر
في الوقت الذي كان يتحدث فيه بيسكو تقول
اوكرانيا انها حققت تقدما على الارض في
باخموت اهم بقعه من الصراع بين الجانبين
ومدينه المعركه الاطول في الحرب
الاوكرانيه بحسب قائد القوات البريه في
الجيش الاوكراني اوليكسكي فان القوات
الاوكرانيه شنت هجوما مضادا في باخموت
واجبرت القوات الروسيه على التراجع في بعض
الاماكن الى مسافه تصل الى كيلو مترين
فحتى مقاتلوا فاغنر وفقا لسيرسكي استبدلوا
في بعض الاماكن بوحدات من الجيش النظامي
الروسي وهي اقل استعدادا العمليه الخاصه
كما وصفها اجبرت روسيا على شنها ولم تكن
خيارا بسبب ما ارتكبته الدول الغربيه من
الاشياء السيئه والاخطاء فالغرب وفقا لرجل
الكريملين خدع روسيا بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي من خلال توسيع البنيه التحتيه
والعسكريه لحلف الناتو باتجاه الحدود
الروسيه حدود شنت موسكو حربا من اجل
تامينها لكنها باتت عرضه للاستهداف اكثر
رائد المصطفى العربيه
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل معي من
العاصمه الدنماركيه الان الصحفي المتخصص
في الشان الروسي سامر الياس سامر اهلا
وسهلا بك لماذا تاخر هذا الهجوم الاوكراني
الكبير والمضاد الذي كثر الحديث عنه وهل
هنالك بالفعل او بالاصل مثل هكذا هجوم
سامر ام لا يعني ما يجري هو في اطار الحرب
النفسيه بين الطرفين
تحيه طيبه نعم هذا الهجوم تاخر كثيرا نظرا
لعدم استعداد الجانب الاوكراني بشكل اساسي
عدم وجود قوه بشريه كبيره الخبراء
العسكريون يقولون بان القوه اذا كانت
مهاجمه يجب ان تكون سته اضعاف القوى
المدافعه ليس لدى اوكرانيا العدد الكبير
من اجل تامين جبهه نحو 100 كم على سبيل
المثال لكي تشن هجوما في منطقه زباروجيا
او تشون في منطقه خرسون او في منطقه لذلك
هذه جبهات طويله طول الجبهه اكثر من الف
كيلو متر هذا من جانب من جانب اخر
اوكرانيا لم تحصل على اسلحه كافيه حتى
الان رغم التصريحات الامريكيه تستطيع ان
تحقق تغيرا نوعيا اليوم هناك حديث عن ان
بريطانيا سوف تزود اوكرانيا بنوع من
الصواريخ يمكن ان يصل الى 250 كيلو متر
هذا يمكن ان يؤدي الى قطع الخطوط
اللوجستيه بالنسبه لي الجانب الروسي ويمكن
ان يغير المعادله بشكل
كبير لكن قبل ذلك الجانب الغربي يرفض
تزويد اوكرانيا بصواريخ بعيده المدى اكثر
من 80 كيلو متر في حاله هاي مارس وكذلك
يرفض تزويد اوكرانيا بطائرات اف 16 قادره
على ضرب القواعد العسكريه الروسيه
الموجوده بشكل خاص في شبه جزيره القرم
العمق الاستراتيجي لمنطقتي خرسون ومنطقه
الجانب الاوكراني ربما اراد الحصول على
مزيد من الاسلحه من الغرب لذلك كان يشير
بان هناك هجوما فيه للحصول على اكبر قدر
من المساعده ربما لشن بعض الهجمات
الموضعيه وربما بشكل اساسي من اجل صد اي
تقدم روسي وهو ما
بستمر لنعود لنعود الى المربع الاول يعني
قيل انت تعرف قيل ان الهدف من هذه الحرب
هو استنزاف روسيا حتى اخر رمق من اجل
احداث تغيير سياسي في موسكو بعد نحو سنه
واربعه اشهر طيب
هل تح قق ذلك ام لا ما تحقق هو العكس الذي
يستنزف الان هو الغرب وتحديدا الاتحاد
الاوروبي
يعني الجانبان مستنزفان حقيقه لكن انا ارى
بان المواجهه الغربيه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه التقديرات تشير الى ان
واشنطن قدمت تبرعات بقدر 37 مليار دولار
حتى الان من الاسلحه لاوكرانيا وهذا مبلغ
زهيد جدا نظرا للكلفه الكبيره التي
تكبدتها روسيا اقتصاديا بسبب عشر موجات من
العقوبات الاقتصاديه بسبب ايضا استنزاف
انواع كثيره من الاسلحه وكشف اسرار انواع
كثيره من الاسلحه الروسيه ايضا استنزاف
الجانب الروسي عسكريا وسياسيا ايضا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تسعى عبر
اتهام الرئيس بلادي مربوطين وتوجيه تهمه
له بمحكمه المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
باستنزاف روسيا على الاقل بوجهه نظر
العالم وعدم السماح لكثير من دول العالم
ببناء علاقات مع روسيا عبر اتهام الرئيس
بانه مجرم حرب هناك مكاسب سياسيه اعتقد
كبيره حققها الغربونات مكاسب عسكريه
المصانع العسكريه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انت تعلم بان صناعه الحرب هي
اكثر الصناعات ربحا في العالم الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والمصانع العسكريه
الامريكيه والمصانع العسكريه في اوروبا
بدات
تشتغل بكامل طاقتها التشغيليه لانتاج
اسلحه وهي مكاسب ماليه وغير ذلك لكن ستعمل
انا
عفوا بجمله واحده وربما اكثر تضررا ربما
من هذه الحرب من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه المستفيده لكن روسيا خاسره
والاتحاد الاوروبي خاتران في هذه الحرب
والاكثر خساره هو الشعب الاوكراني الذي
تقام به معركه بالوكاله على ارضه بين
روسيا والغرب فقط تصديقا لكلامك يعني في
بعض كليات الاقتصاد الان تدرس ماده اسمها
الوورد
اقتصاد اعمال الحرب من العاصمه الدنماركيه
كوبنهاجن الصحفيه تخص
ص بشان الروسي سامر الياس شكرا جزيلا
السامر على هذه المشاركه
على الارض تواصلوا روسيا التمسك بمكاسبها
في الميدان بل وتريد المزيد من خلال
التكثيف وتيره التدريبات العسكريه وايضا
تطوير ترسانتها العسكريه من بينها منظومه
صواريخ يارس المتطوره والمزوده بصواريخ
باليستيه عابره للقاره منظومه صواريخ
المتطوره او كما يطلق عليها حلف شمال
الاطلسي اس اس 29 هي منظومه استراتيجيه
مزوده بالصواريخ باليستيا عابره للقارات
هذه الصواريخ مجهزه برؤوس نوويه حراريه
تعمل بالوقود الصلب وكلمه يارس بالروسيه
هي اختصار لصاروخ الرضع النووي اغلب خصائص
تلك المنظومه التقنيه التي دخلت الخدمه
لاول مره في عام 2010 لا تزال السريه غير
انها تعد الاكثر تطورا بعد صواريخ سارمات
وجاءت كتعديل محدث لصواريخ حيث يبلغ
صاروخيار ثلاثه وعشرين مترا وقطر قدره
مترا والوزن عند الاطلاق يبلغ 46 طنا
بسرعه تتعدى سرعه الصوت اربعه عشره مره
يصل مدى صاروخ يارس الى 12 الف كيلو متر
وهو قادر على اصابه اي هدف على سطح الارض
صواريخ يارس تسير على هيكل مكون من سته
عشره عجله حيث ان الصاروخ الواحد يمكن ان
يحمل سته رؤوس نوويه بقوه تتراوح بين 150
وخمسمائه تمتلك خاصيه استهداف منفصله
اضافه لمدى الصاروخ تعتبر خاصيته الفرط
صوتيه اهم مميزاته القدره التفجيريه
الاجماليه للرؤوس النوويه التي يحملها
صاروخ يارس يمكنها ان تعادل مليون طن وهنا
يجب الاشاره الى ان الصاروخ يعتمد على
نظام غلونات الروسي المعادلي لنظام جي بي
اس الامريكي تمتلك روسيا ما يزيد عن 147
صاروخا من هذا النوع بما فيها
135 منصه متحركه و12 منصه ثابته واشنطن
فسرت فسرت تطوير موسكو لهذا النوع من
الصواريخ بالالتفاف على معاهده ستارت التي
تقيد اعداد صواريخ توبول
نشاطها الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
مرشح انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه محرم انجاز
ينسحب من السباق الرئاسي
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه امرت المحكمه العليا الباكستانيه
باطلاق سراح رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
خان وقالت المحكمه العليا ان اعتقال عمران
خان لم يكن قانونيا وان عليه المثول مره
اخرى امام محكمه اسلام اباد العليا من جهه
قال رئيس الوزراء السابق انه تم اختطافه
من محكمه اسلام اباد العليا وتعرض للضرب
على يد قوات الامن واضاف عمران خان انه لم
يكن على علم بالاضطرابات التي حدثت في
البلاد اعتقاله
قوات الجيش الباكستاني كانت قد انتشرت في
العاصمه اسلام اباد للتصدي لمظاهرات قام
بها انصار الرئيس الوزراء السابق عمران
واشتبك انصار خان مع قوات الامن في مدن
عده متهمين الجيش بتدبير مؤامره للاطاحه
برئيس الوزراء السابق كما تم القاء القبض
على عده مسؤولين في حركه انصاف بتهم
تدبيرهم لهذه المظاهره
الى اسلام اباد مجددا ينضم اليه لمزيد من
المتابعه مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
المزيني الذي يتابع هذه التطورات عبد
الرحمن اهلا وسهلا بك جديد المشهد السياسي
في باكستان واين هو الان عمران خان يعني
طالما تاكد اطلاق سراحه هل عاد الى منزله
ام ماذا
حقيقه هناك جدل قضائي وسياسي يثار الان
حول قرار المحكمه العليا الدستوريه
الافراج عن رئيس الوزراء السابق عمران خان
واعتبار قرار
اعتقاله غير قانوني المحكمه العليا
الدستوريه رفضت طلبا لرئيس الوزراء السابق
عمران بالتوجه الى
المنازل احد المنازل الخاصه به في ضواحي
العاصمه وذلك بناء على
رغبه او طلب من مفتش عن شرطه العاصمه
لاسباب وصف هذه الامنيه وخوفا على حياته
المحكمه طلبت من عمران خان التوجه الى بيت
او ضيافه التابع لمجمع الشرطه في العاصمه
اسامه
تم نقل او يجري الان نقل عمران خان الى
منزل الضيافه سيكون بامكانه
لقاء عدد من انصاره او
المساعديه خلال مكسي في هذا المنزل الى
حين مثوله يوم غد الجمعه امام محكمه
العليا لتقرر او تبث في
القضيه التي اعتقل على خلفيتها من المتوقع
ان يقدم فريق الفريق القانوني لامران خان
طلبا بحصوله على كفاله مؤقته ضد الاعتقال
على خلفيه القضيه فور قرار المحكمه العليا
الدستوريه كانت هناك حاله من الابتهاج لدى
انصار رئيس وزراء السابق عمران خان بعض
انصار او العشرات من انصاري حاولوا
الاقتراب من ما يعرف هنا بالمنطقه الحمراء
حيث كانت تجري المحاكمه لكن قوات الشرطه
منعتهم
قامت باطلاق عاهره الغاز المسيل المسيل
للدموع لت عبد الرحمن بس انت وفق متابعتك
لو سمحت لي هل قرار اطلاق صراع عمران خان
يحل المشكله ولو مرحليا ام لا يعني ينزع
فتيل التازم من الشارع ام لا
كل ذلك يعني السنوريات مفتوحه على كافه
الاحتمالات ولكن ذلك يعتمد على ما سيقوله
عمران خان لانصاره وما سيقرره
ما ستقرره محكمه العليا وما ستقررها
الحكومه هناك اجتماع للجنه الامن القومي
الباكستانيه المواقف التي صدرت مبدئيا عن
الحكوميه الحكومه كان هناك
انتقاد
باتجاه المحكمه العليا في اصدار
امر بالافراج
وزيره الاعلام الباكستانيه عن انه كيف
يمكن لشخص لجا الى العنف وحظ انصاره على
العنف كيف يمكن له ان يحصل على رعايه
مفضله او
معامله تفضيليه من المحكمه العليا
هناك ايضا في داخل ائتلاف الحاكم هناك
اصوات تطالب عدم الافراج عن عمران خان
وهذا ربما يوم غد سوف تتضح الصوره اكثر من
اسلام اباد مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن
المزيني شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن على كل
هذه المتابعه
قالت مصادر في الجيش السوداني انه تم
اطلاق المرحله الاخيره للسيطره على خرطوم
بحري وذلك بعد السيطره على جسر الحلفايه
وتمركز الجيش في محيطه من الناحيتين واكد
المصدر ان الجيش السوداني تمكن من فرض
مجموعات الدعم السريع من مناطق شرق
الخرطوم بحري
وفيما تستمر المحادثات بين وفدي الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع في جده بوساطه
سعوديه امريكيه اكد الناطق باسم العمليه
السياسيه خالد عمر يوسف اكد ان تفاؤلا
حذرا بات يلوح في الافق على الرغم من
الاشتباكات المستمره في العاصمه الخرطوم
وان المباحثات في جده باتت تقترب من
التوصل الى اتفاق وقف اطلاق النار في اي
لحظه كما اشار الى احتمال اتفاق الجيش
والدعم السريع على انهاء الازمه والاقتتال
الدائر في السودان
وشدد الناطق باسم العمليه السياسيه على ان
حل الازمه التي تعيشها البلاد هو الخيار
السلمي
على كل لمزيد من المتابعه معي هنا في
الاستوديو لينا يعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه
في السودان لنهلا وسهلا بك قبل ان اسالك
لينا عن هل رشح شيء ما عن محادثات جدا اخر
المعلومات الميدانيه الوارده من السودان
تحديدا الخرطوم هل فعلا تاكدت هذه
المعلومات بان الجيش يتقدم في الخرطوم
بحري
نعم طالب الجيش تقدم امس فعليا وهو ما
وثقته عدسات المواطنين عبر هواتفهم الجيش
تقدم في كثير من المناطق ولكن اليوم ايضا
الدعم السريع تقدم في هذه المناطق لماذا
لان الجيش اجرى تمشيط كبير في بحري وابعد
قوات الدعم السريع لكنه لم يضع ارتكازات
بالتالي هناك بعض القوات عادت مجددا في
بعض المناطق لكن التقدم الكبير للجيش
السوداني في منطقه بحري بحسب المواطنين هو
واضح للعيان منذ امس امس كانت هناك معارك
مشتده بدات في الصباح الباكر وانتهت عصرا
هذه المعارك ابعدت قوات الدعم السريع في
كثير من المناطق التي كانوا يتمركزون فيها
ولكن هناك عوده بسيطه الى مناطق اخرى طيب
بالنسبه الى المحادثات الماراثونيه التي
تجري في جده هل رشح اي شيء وهل المؤشرات
المتوفره لديك تشير الى تفاؤل ام الى
تشاؤم ام الى ماذا هناك تفاؤل لكن ايضا
هناك النظر في كيفيه تطبيق هذا الاتفاق
بحسب مصادر دبلوماسيه تحدثنا اليها وكما
تحدثنا ايضا الى الطرفين هناك لغه جديده
ورغم ان هذا الحوار
والمفاوضات هي غير مباشره بينهما هي بين
الوساطه او مع الوساطه السعوديه الامريكيه
لكن هناك ما يقارب اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
لكن هناك بنود ما زالت معلقه يجري النقاش
حولها ان تمت الاتفاق عليها سيتم هناك
توقيع هذا التوقيع سيشمل الجزء الاول من
المفاوضات المتمثله بوقف اطلاق النار
وايصال المساعدات الانسانيه هذا لا يعني
طبعا حدوث سلام في السودان من هناك مرحله
اخرى من المفاوضات اليه في هذه المرحله هو
تمديد وقف اطلاق النار او لنقل وقف اطلاق
نار شامل ولكن كل طرف يظل على مواقعه هل
الامور بهذا الاتجاه لا اعتقد انها ستسير
باتجاهنا كل طرف سيكون بمواقع لان هذا
يعني عدم الالتزام بالهد الهدنه اعلنها
الدعم السريع اعلنها الجيش السوداني لكن
كلا الطرفين لم يلتزم بها لا هذه
المفاوضات هي لتاكيد التزام الاطراف لوضع
ربما اليه للمراقبه لابعاد الاطراف من
المواقع التي تشهد اشتباك لايصال هذه
المساعدات طالما ان هناك مساعدات ستصل الى
المواطنين وهي ليست في منطقه محدده هذا
يعني ضروره ان تبتعد هذه المظاهر العسكريه
من الاحياء وهذا يعني بحسب ما طالب الجيش
ان يسحب الدعم السريع من العاصمه وان يكون
في معسكر واحد وهو الامر الذي كان يتحفظ
عليه الدعم السريع ولكن تبقت قليل من
التفاصيل ان تمت الموافقه عليها سنشهد
توقيع اولي ثم بعد ذلك مفاوضات سياسيه
جديده لنا يعقوب مديره مكتب العربيه في
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
ونتابع هذه النشره من العربيه لم تقتصر
تداعيات الاشتباكات المسلحه المستمره بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع على الصعيد
السياسي والامني والاقتصادي فحسب بل خيمت
على احلام الرياضيين وقد حال استمرار
الاقتتال دون تمكن فريق العاب القوى
لولايه جنوب دارفور من السفر للتحضير
للمشاركه في اولمبياد العاب القوى في
باريس مضطرهم للتمرن تحت اصوات الرصاص على
امل ان يتحسن الوضع ليتمكنوا من المشاركه
في هذه المسابقه وسط المعارك وتحت مرمى
النيران لم تتوقف ند موسى ورفقائها من
مواصله عمليات الاعداد الخاص برياضه العاب
القوى هنا بمدينه نيالا ولايه جنوب دارفور
غربيه السودان المعارك وتوترات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع لم تمنعهم من التمسك بحلمهم
اعمل انجاز في الولايه وفي السودان عام
يعني اكون لعبه دوليه في السودان وخارج
السودان والله رغم المشاكل دي نحنا ما
وقفنا من تماريننا مواصلين في التمارين
رغم الضغوطات الحاصله دي شغالين فيها
اربعه اعوام كامله ظل الفريق يواصل
الاعدادات بهدف المشاركه في اولمبياد
باريس هذا العام المدرب المشرف عليهم
يتمنى عوده الاوضاع الى طبيعتها لاستكمال
المشوار يعني احنا الان يعني في مرحله
اولمبيادة باريس اقتربت والان اسلم بامور
بازمه ان احنا كنا حسب التخطيط بتاعنا
هناخد معسكر خارجي في اثيوبيا او في كينيا
اعداد لكن للاسف الان يبدو بانه احلامنا
تبعثرت حلم بتاع سته خمسه سنوات مجهود
تمارين صباح مساء جبال سهول مرتفعات يبدو
بانها سوف تتبخر لانه الان الوضع لا يسر
لا يسر وانت تعلم ذلك اقليم دارفور ظل
لسنوات عديده يشهد ظروفا معقده بسبب الحرب
المتواصل
وبات الطريق الاوحد لتجاوز هذه الصعاب هو
السعي الدائم لبلوغ الاهداف وتحقيق
الاحلامة ونحن كلعبين والله ممارسين
تمارين على حسب الكوارث اللي وقعت فينا
وبذلك نتحدث يا عبد لكي يعني مستوانا ما
ينزل لان اللاعب او القوه لو وقف من
التمارين الاعداء بتاعه بتقل ما بينفع
الفائز في حرب نادي خسران بصراحه يعني
احنا بقدر ما نملك بخدر ما نملك من مجهود
رياادي نحاول ننمي الوطن ما بنحاول ندمر
الوطن على الرغم مما تمر به البلاد مصاعب
يظل الحلم قائما من اجل صناعه واقع افضل
[موسيقى]
قال مرشح انتخابات الرئاسه التركيه محرم
انجي انه قرر الانسحاب من السباق ويعد
انجي واحدا من اربعه مرشحين للرئاسه الى
جانب اردوغان وكمال كليتش
وقالت وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه ان هذه
الخطوه قد تجعل المعارضه تفوز في اول جوله
وكان استطلاع راي سابق قد اظهر ان اردوغان
يتخلف عن كليتش دار ابلو باكثر من خمس
نقاط مئويه
[موسيقى]
العوده الى الاحداث والمواجهات
في بين اسرائيل وقطاع غزه رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي يقول في خبر العاجل الان اننا
لا نزال في منتصف المعركه سواء في الهجوم
او الدفاع كما ترون على الشاشه التعديلات
الاخيره على قانون الانتخابات التركيه
سيكون لها تاثير مباشر على كيفيه تشكيل
البرلمان الجديد كما ستغير من استراتيجيه
الاحزاب للفوز بالمقاعد
المشهد الانتخابي المتعلق بالبرلمان
التركي في انتخابات 2023 بتركيا مسار
مختلف عن سابقيه خاصه فيما يتعلق بتاثير
التعديلات في قانون الانتخابات التي اقرها
البرلمان في ابريل الماضي ودخلت حيز
التنفيذ في مارس الماضي تلك التعديلات
وخفضت الحد الادنى المطلوب من الاصوات
لدخول الحزب السياسي للبرلمان الى سبعه في
المئه بدلا من عشره في المئه حيث تمنع
العتبه الانتخابيه اي حزب يحصل على اقل من
سبعه في المئه على مستوى البلاد من شغل
مقعد في البرلمان حتى لو جاء اولا في
دائره انتخابيه معينه يا نص التعديل
الانتخابي ايضا على ضروره ان يكون الحزب
السياسي الراغب في المشاركه بالانتخابات
قد عقد لمرتين متتاليتين مؤتمراته الكبرى
في الولايات والاقذيه فيما يتضمن القرار
تعديلا بمنع انتقال النواب من حزب الى اخر
من اجل تسهيلات الدخول في الانتخابات
ففي انتخابات عام 2018 انتقل 15 نائبا من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري الى حزب الخير
لتمكينهم من دخول الانتخابات حيث كان
قانون الانتخابات يشترط تشكيل كتله نيابيه
للحزب داخل البرلمان مؤلفه من عشرين نائبا
ليتاح له خوض الانتخابات المقبله
وبالتعديل الجديد لن يكون ذلك متاحا في
القانون السابق كانت الاحزاب المتحالفه
تتمكن من تجاوز العتبه الانتخابيه في عموم
تركيا من خلال التحالف لكن في التعديل
الاخير يتم الحصول على مقاعد برلمانيه عن
طريق اصواتهم الانتخابيه اي انهم لن
يستفيدوا من الاصوات الزائده وبالتالي
فانه لن يتم تمثيله الاحزاب في البرلمان
عبر الاصوات الفائضه
[موسيقى]
زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 1992 عمل في
مؤسسه الضمان الاجتماعي من
1997 حتى
1999 تولى اداره مؤسسه الضمان الاجتماعي
عام 2002 بدا نشاطه السياسي في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري
انتخابات البرلمان التركي نوفمبر 2002 ثم
في اغسطس 2007 فاز بعضويه البرلمان في
الدائره الثانيه في اسطنبول
2010 انتخب رئيسا الحزب الشعبي الجمهوري
بعد استقاله سلفه دينيز بايكال
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
البرلمان الاوروبي صادق على قواعد جديده
لتقليل مخاطر استخدام الذكاء الصناعي
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه قال مركز رصد النزوح الداخلي
ومقره ومقره جنيف ان عدد النازحين حول
العالم وصل الى رقم قياسي العمل الماضي اذ
سجل اكثر من 71 مليون نازح بسبب الحرب في
اوكرانيا وبسبب التغيرات المناخيه واضاف
مركز الارصاد ان هذا العدد يشكل زياده
بنسبه 20% منذ عام 2021 مع فرار الناس
بحثا عن الامام ووفقا للمركز فقد تسببت
الحرب في اوكرانيا في نزوح ما يقرب من 17
مليون اوكراني العمل الماضي فيما تسبب
الصراع والعنف في نزوح
28.3 مليون حول العالم وهي حصيله اعلى
بثلاث مرات عن المتوسط السنوي للعقد
الماضي
بينما اشار المركز الى ان عدد النازحين
العام الماضي والذي بلغ نحو ثلاثه 33
مليون شخص جاء بسبب كوارث الفيضانات
والجفاف والانهيارات الارضيه
اذهب الى لندن لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم اليه من هناك الخبير
القانوني في شؤون الهجره واللجوء احمد
سعدون استاذ احمد اهلا وسهلا بك الى اي
مدى هذه الارقام خطره وخطيره جدا واين قوس
خطر تدق برايك
كل الشكر والامتنان زميل طالب وشكر موصول
لكادر قناه العربيه على التغطيه طبعا انا
من وجهه نظري القانونيه انه اصلا هذا
العدد يعني
اكبر انه
اللي متوقع انه يذكر في التقرير على اي
حال اللي حصل يعني غير خاف عن حضرتك انه
الحروب لعبت دور خطير وكبير والحرب
الاخيره الاوكرانيه هي مثال حقيقي ما يحصل
في سوريا ما يحصل في اليمن كذلك مخاطر
وكوارث
الفياضانات
والبيئه لعبه دور كبير مع ذلك يعني ما
قامت به الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وامريكا
وبريطانيا هو يعني خجول شيء خجول من من
مما يحصل لان هذه الدول هي موقعه على
معاهدات معاهده 1951 لح الطالبي اللي في
حاله عودتهم الى بلدهم الاصل بخطر هذا
اللي يحصل والقادم اسوا يعني هذا الصيف هو
سوف يكون صيف ساخن بمعنى الكلمه اتجاه
موجه كبيره باتجاه اوروبا طيب
استاذ احمد من يجب ان يتحمل المسؤوليه
يعني اذا بدنا نحدد المسؤوليات في كوارث
طبيعيه هذا مفهوم ولكن ماذا بالنسبه الى
الدول الفاعله والكبرى ماذا باستطاعه هذه
الدول القيام به للتقليل من هذه الكارثه
ام لا بعض هذه الدول مستفيده بشكل او باخر
كما يقول البعض
طبعا
اضرب لك مثال وانا مسؤول قانونيا عن
الحديث العراق الان يمر في ظروف من 2003
لحد هذه اللحظه بامانه 99% من الشعب
العراقي يعني يود المغادره بامانه وبثقه
لانه
بسبب الفساد المالي والاداري بسبب بسبب
نقص الخدمات انا كنت في زياره خاطفه الى
العراق شعرت بالحزن وبالالم يعني 1970
اكثر بكثير وافضل العيش من ذيك الفتره هذا
اللي يحصل سوريا الان بلد بلد كارثي الان
ليبيا اليمن اللي يحصل على انه دول
اوروبيه غير ما مستفيده باستثناء لربما
عندما يحصل على الاقامه بعدد الاصابع او
بالعشرات يندمجون بالمجتمع عامل اللغه
عامر رئيسي زميل طالب
الشخص اللي هو اصلا في بلده بامكاننا ان
يتميز في ويظهر ويندمج بالمجتمع في تلك
البلدان فلذلك الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
يعني هناك تقصير كبير الضغط الان على
بريطانيا يعني حتى حضرتك انا اكثر مع
قناتكم الكريمه انه اكثر من 45 الف لاجئ
وصلوا خلال هاي سنتين البريطانيا استاذ
احمد للاسف للاسف يعني كان بيودي ان اكمل
ولكن لضيق الوقت من لندن احمد سعدون
الخبير القانوني في شؤون الهجره ولجوء
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
صادقت لجنه الحريات في البرلمان الاوروبيه
على قواعد جديده تهدف لتقليل مخاطر
استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي فيما يخص
البيانات الشخصيه للمستخدمين
التصويت على القواعد تم على مستوى اللجنه
بنتيجه 84
مع مقابل سبعه معارضين وسيكون التصويت بعد
اسبوعين على مستوى دوره البرلمان العامه
ويتطلب تنفيذ القواعد في حال المصادقه
عليها في البرلمان موافقه الدول الاعضاء
في الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتتبنى القواعد مبادئ غير تمييزيه بهدف
حظر الانظمه ذات المخاطر العاليه ومنع
استهداف المواطنين من خلال تقنيات الذكاء
الاصطناعي
شكرا لزياده اعزائي المشاهدين نشره
الخامسه انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات